kamchatka là bas tout au bout du monde
l'ultime contrées sauvages de la planète
un seul peuple domine ces immensités
ils attendent la fin d'un interminable
hiver lui moins huit jours
avec le printemps qui vient les
températures grimpent doucement et tous
les ours sorte un nom de leur tanière
quand on trouve un endroit favorable on
y est rarement seuls les ours n'aimant
guère la promiscuité les tensions
s'avivent vite entre les maires
des tensions qui ne vont faire que
s'accroître car en quelques jours le lac
va accueillir la plus forte
concentration d'ours au monde
la mère ne se bat pas seulement pour un
poisson de plus à pêcher elle défend la
vie la sécurité de ses enfants
et c'est cette motivation absolue
viscérale qui la rend plus forte
les maires ne sont pas au bout de leurs
peines les tensions culmineront encore
plus tard quand les mâles ce qu'elles
craignent par dessus tout arriveront à
leur tour en masse